and now this what a joy for us over his
decades-long career award-winning
journalist in 60 minute correspondent
Scott Pelley has been on the front lines
to cover events that changed the world
his new memoir truth worth telling a
reporter's search for meaning in the
stories of our times highlights
individuals who found purpose during
life-changing moments of history he
writes about his conversations with
Marines stationed in Afghanistan parents
of Sandy Hook shooting victims and even
music icon Bruce Springsteen Scott
Pelley is here first on CBS this morning
to talk about his book Scott
congratulations well Roy thank you very
much good morning great to be with you
you start the book after the 2015 Paris
attack why there you know it occurred to
me there John that there were people
bringing candles to this makeshift
memorial in Paris for the hundred and
twenty people who were killed on that
day and they had this look of
bewilderment on their face and it
occurred to me that I'd seen that before
I'd seen it on 9/11 at the World Trade
Center I'd seen it in Oklahoma City
after the bombing of the murrah Federal
Building I'd seen again and again
throughout my entire career and it
occurred to me that those people were
asking the question what's the meaning
of life and I thought you know we're
asking the wrong question don't ask the
meaning of life life is asking what's
the meaning of you and in that idea I
began to think about all these people
that I had met over the years the people
that you were just talking about in the
intro and how they had discovered the
meaning of their lives the virtue in
life in some of the most challenging
events of our times you know I loved the
title of the book
Scott truth worth telling because we're
living in a place now at this time in
society where the press journalism is
under attack and you point out very
clearly that there's no democracy
without journalism I think that's such
an important message to send this
particular time you know
Gail the the American people have to
have independent generally reliable
information to make decisions about
their own lives and the lives of the
country
the founders were counting on us to be
proactive citizens they gave us the
power in this country and the only way
we can exercise that power is with
credible information Madison James
Madison described freedom of the press
as the right that guarantees all the
others you know Scott you and I both
often talked about Victor Frankel's book
man's search for meaning and it struck
me when I was reading some of these
accounts especially of lance corporal
David Hall who was killed in Afghanistan
and because Frankel writes this
everything can be taken from you but one
thing the last human freedom to choose
one's attitude and you talk about Lance
Corporal Hall and devotion and why he
did what he did he lost his life in
Afghanistan because of the choices that
he made absolutely Frankel of course the
Holocaust survivor survivor who wrote
that tremendous book in the 1940s David
Hall was the minesweeper at the head of
the column every day and one point they
took his minesweeper away from him and
gave him a promotion and he he wouldn't
take it he wanted the minesweeper back
because of the unambiguous virtue of
what he was doing
sweeping the path for his fellow Marines
and protecting his fellow Marines the
beginning chapter in the book is called
gallantry and it's about what I saw at
the World Trade Center on 9/11 yeah with
the fire department of the city of New
York and it occurred to me that those
343 firefighters who were killed that
day the largest loss of life of any
emergency service in history those
firefighters went up those stairs they
didn't know yeah what 9/11 it was out
they didn't know why the World Trade
Center had been attacked but it didn't
matter yeah because they knew what they
were about everybody that knows you
Scott Pelley would not call you a liar
liar pants on fire but you admit you
lied about your age at the beginning
about that and why did you bring it up I
my my quest my quest for truth began for
the lie I wanted a job as a copy boy in
the public Avalanche Journal newspaper
and they only hired kids who were 16 I
was 15 and so I fibbed about my age and
my mom would drop me every day two
blocks from the papers so people
couldn't see I didn't have a driver to
but from the age of 15 I've been doing
this so it's been a long long road it's
worked out okay the name of the book
your first book congratulations thank
you god we love it truth worth telling a
reporter search for meaning in the
stories of our times and he tells a lot
of stories Thank You Scott Pelley thank
you always great to have you